season two of jujitsu Kaizen begins 12
years ago when Gojo was a student at Jiu
Jitsu high at the time his best friend
was Suga regaito who's a special great
sorcerer with the ability to control
curse Spirits at the start of episode 1
they save meimei and uttahime from a
haunted mansion and shortly after this
they're given a brand new Mission from a
young principal Yaga basically in
Jujitsu High there's an immortal
sorcerer called tengen and every 500
years tengen needs to absorb another
person in order for them to stay human
this time around tengen has to absorb a
girl called Rico Omani but there are a
couple groups of people who don't want
this to happen the first group is called
q and they're basically Jiu Jitsu
terrorists and the second is a religious
group that once tang in to stay pure as
a result they hired megami's dad to kill
Rico and his ghetto and goji's
responsibility to protect her however
when they arrived to pick her up the
girl gets attacked by q and Falls head
first out of this super tall building
luckily ghetto was able to use his
curses to fly in and he grabs her before
she gets close to hitting the ground